many conspiracy channels are popping up
some are even touting queue claiming
that billionaires are psychopathic
pedophiles kovat is a planned emic to
put out 5g for mind control and
population reduction and basically
offloading all problems with the world
to outside themselves to create some
sort of pseudo Awakening which has
already become violent and seems to be
forgetting the cardinal rule of
consciousness the outer world is a
reflection of our inner world now I'm
not telling everyone to meditate
although it is a proven way to create
more harmony in your mind family and
world what I am saying is why are people
becoming famous right now through
demagoguery preying on people's fear
instincts that they need to prevent a
totalitarian New World Order AI agenda
what's the actual probability that all
these conspiracies have any connection
to each other and this agenda
we all understand the importance of the
world's most prominent assassinations
events and the possibility space of the
future so why not focus all your energy
on transforming yourself and holding
only the highest civilizational
flourishing in mind you are not 100%
good and Bill Gates is not 100% bad
anyone who thinks that has fallen into
the binary trap we are all mixes of both
our life's work lies in realizing this
doing self work to integrate the shadow
and building the more beautiful world
our hearts know is possible so of course
research the most salient events of the
past but then set your goal on the
brightest future use a laser-like focus
to transform yourself and make art
entrepreneurship science to get us there
so whether Abe Lincoln was actually
half-black the Federal Reserve and
government debt are surreptitious
slavery for JFK / 9/11 were inside jobs
is old news compared to what ethics and
morals we use to build the next largest
Internet platforms crypto currencies and
a eyes
we don't actually live on a finite
planet
don't let that myth of scarcity consume
you Einstein's mass-energy equivalence
shows that technology like Star Trek's
replicator are possible and we can have
unlimited free energy forever by
replicating the cosmic process of the
Sun on earth through controlled fusion
of hydrogen this needs to be a top
priority to heal respect and cherish our
interdependence with the earth not to
virtue signal and green wash selling
fear and scarcity but rather build the
abundant future where all people are
flourishing and have a stake in our
collective success there is a consistent
pattern in history where people
promulgate fear and uncertainty about
the future and entrenched interests
fight to retain the status quo but we
should now be wise enough to not fail
the marshmallow experiment letting our
short-term gratification for technology
like 5g seduce us without conducting
many more longitudinal studies on the
health effects and exploring additional
creative options of how to deliver more
effective technology
same for understanding the central dogma
of biology the more we understand the
code of life the more we become the
interstellar gods we are destined to be
we are explorers and creatives
we just need to ground the original
living wisdom of Earth into our psyche
as we evolved to our highest potential
it has been said for thousands of years
love everyone and tell the truth stop
obsessing over the conspiracy being in
the other recognize how everything in
our reality serves an evolutionary
purpose and become the change you wish
to see in the world
[Music]
you